[Música]
y salud en directo américa de france 24
me acompaña en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida hoy vamos a hablar de
la adicción al tabaco y en los circuitos
cerebrales que están relacionados con
esta adicción cierra el muy buenos días
imagínate 30 personas que fumaban más de
20 cigarrillos al día les da un ictus
que recordemos que es cuando la sangre
deja de llegar al cerebro y dejan de
tener la necesidad y la adicción de
fumar estos son los casos que estudiaron
un grupo de científicos en estados
unidos y también en finlandia y pues
permitieron mapear un poco mejor estos
circuitos y esas áreas cerebrales que
están relacionadas con las adicciones en
este caso particularmente con la
adicción al tabaco entonces pues para
analizar para comentar esta noticia
estamos con el doctor oscar a franco
profesor de epidemiología y de salud
pública de la universidad de berna
doctor muy buen miércoles y gracias por
acompañarnos para empezar simplemente
cuéntenos cuáles son estas áreas y estos
circuitos cerebrales que se han
identificado en estos estudios
siempre me logra recordar que las
adicciones son un problema de salud
pública que según la oim es la
organización mundial de la salud afecta
entre un 10 y 20 por ciento de la
población mundial durante mucho tiempo
se ha discutido si es un problema de
moral de voluntad si es un problema de
cómo nos educan en la casa o si es una
enfermedad lo que vemos aquí es que esos
investigadores confirman que hay
aspectos fisiológicos físicos que están
realmente relacionados con la enfermedad
más allá de encontrar zonas específicas
se encontraron múltiples zonas en el
cerebro que compartían un patrón de
conectividad similar que seguía varios
parámetros por un lugar teníamos un
patrón de conectividad positiva entre el
circulado dorsal la corteza prefrontal
lateral y la ínsula y un patrón de
conectividad negativa entre la corteza
prefrontal medial y temporal básicamente
más allá de las zonas lo que se
identificasen unos circuitos y esos
circuitos si se interrumpen podrían
ayudar como una forma terapéutica para
poder resolver los problemas de las
adicciones doctor los saludo buen
miércoles también le pregunto si
coinciden los circuitos afectados con
otra adicciones como por ejemplo lo es
el alcohol
si este es uno de los grandes hallazgos
de estos investigadores porque toman un
grupo de pacientes separado
independiente que los evalúan para el
riesgo de tener adicciones al alcohol y
encuentro en que la adicción al alcohol
también compartía esa conectividad en
esos circuitos en los mismos circuitos
que se encontraron para la nicotina esto
quiere decir que parece que estos
circuitos podrían ser responsables no
solamente de estos dos tipos de
adicciones sino de muchos más lo que
simplificaría la investigación ahora nos
ayudaría a tener unas medidas
terapéuticas efectivas y que se amplíen
a la población hablando de estas medidas
terapéuticas doctor precisamente no hay
precedentes de terapias más allá de las
adicciones que modifiquen circuitos
cerebrales para curar algún tipo de
dolencia
si estará la neuromodulación que
consiste en esto en modificar o hacerlo
más activo menos activo ciertos
circuitos se ha utilizado de manera
superficial o profunda en el cerebro
para enfermedades como enfermedad del
afecto como la depresión o trastornos
obsesivos compulsivos para las
adicciones hasta ahora la investigación
está avanzando y hasta ahora no se ha
utilizado como un régimen terapéutico
pero este estudio podría abrir esa
puerta para poder ubicar ciertas medidas
que pueden ayudar a las personas con la
adicción para poder dejar de fumar o
dejar de tomar alcohol o sustancias
doctor me pregunto si hace falta en ese
sentido hacer estudios más amplios para
tener datos más concluyentes
sino solamente más amplios es muy
importante entender qué tipo de
estimulación se necesitaría puede ser en
cualquier lugar del circuito qué
ubicación exacta tiene que ser cuánto
tiempo se tiene que modificar y cuánto
tiempo puede durar el efecto que es algo
que tampoco se sabe no se sabe si puede
durar a largo plazo y también sabemos
que las las conectividad de los
circuitos pueden diferenciarse entre
personas entonces se tendría que hacer
una manera mucho más personalizada y
podría ser que diferentes personas
requieran tratamientos distintos
doctora vamos a añadir también que para
referenciar esto es un estudio publicado
hace dos días de un hecho y me dicen que
no lo habíamos dicho por si los
telespectadores quieren referenciar lo
vamos a terminar con un nuevo tema me
pregunta un poco más amplia no estamos
hablando de modificar de la posibidad de
modificar circuitos cerebrales en un
caso como la adicción que ya es un
sistema bastante complejo realmente hay
límites de esas modificaciones o
intervenciones que la ciencia puede
hacer sobre un órgano tan complejo como
el cerebro que modifica pues
comportamientos e incluso creencias
o podría modificar opiniones o conceptos
religiosos o por quién vamos a votar
entonces yo creo que abre una ventana
muy amplia que tiene que elegiste
regirse por parámetros éticos muy claros
para protegerse del mal uso y ya para
terminar yo creo que es importante
recordar que las adicciones a las
sustancias no solamente afecta de unas
grandes personas sino que no son una
enfermedad que son un problema de salud
pública pero también son problemas
complejos que temen e incluyen las
condiciones socioeconómicas la educación
y no hay que resolverlo simplemente
tomarlo como un crimen o criminalizar al
adicto sino ayudar a la persona al al
contexto a la familia ya la comunidad
porque es una enfermedad que afecta a la
comunidad en general así es doctor
muchísimas gracias como siempre por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros todos los
miércoles en este segmento de salud
también gracias mar por toda la
información nosotros lo pasamos a
saludar a nuestra segunda invitada del
día